Speaker 1: The other thing that is happening
that broke is that Donald Trump a deposition,
that video of his deposition where he pleaded
the Fifth Amendment over 400 times was released.
And it is something that was reported on that he
pled the fifth a whole bunch of times. But when
you see it and you see a an ex-president of the
United States of America, someone who again, this
is a turn of phrase I use all the time, who rose
his right hand and and swore a solemn oath, a vow
supposed to be a man of honor to to to support
and defend the Constitution against all enemies,
foreign and domestic, and to to
faithfully execute the duties
of President of the United States.
He gave his word he would do that.
This this person who also on the campaign trail
and over the years has maligned people who chose
to assert their Fifth Amendment right under the
Constitution of the United States to against
self-incrimination. Here's that. First, let's
give you a reminder of Donald Trump's very, very
settled attitude about people who plead the Fifth.
Speaker 5: When you have your staff taking the
Fifth Amendment, taking the Fifth so they're
not prosecuted. When you have the man that
set up the illegal server taking the Fifth,
I think it's disgraceful. Fifth Amendment,
Bob, the mob takes of it. If you're innocent,
why are you taking the Fifth Amendment?
Speaker 4: Fifth Amendment?
Speaker 5: Horrible. Horrible. He
pleaded the Fifth, and that was the end. We never
heard about him again. This is like Watergate,
only it's worse because here our foreign
enemies, we're in a position to hack our
most sensitive national security secrets.
Speaker 1: There is nothing sacred for Donald
Trump. Nothing, because that same man in August
of this past year sat with a deposition with
lawyers asking him questions. Just days after
his home, Mar a Lago, was raided by the FBI and
the Department of Justice for the documents that
endangered our national security. And when asked
questions, he wrote, he read a statement. And
then they asked him a question. He read another
statement and asserted his Fifth Amendment right
under the Constitution. So apparently it's like
the mob. It's if you're innocent, why are you
pleading the Fifth? Just it was, in his words,
against him, except he did it over 400 times.
No, obviously, I'm not going to play a clip
here of him doing it 400 times. But, I mean,
give you the flavor of how this deposition
went down, where he just kept referring to the
statement over and over and over. Watch this.
Speaker 5: Mr. Trump, I understand you have a.
Speaker 1: Statement that you
want to read into the record.
Speaker 5: Yes. Would you please feel
free to start? Thank you very much. This is the
greatest witch hunt in the history of our country.
There has never been another president or perhaps
even another politician who has been persecuted,
harassed, and in every other way unfairly
treated like President Donald J. Trump.
What Letitia James has tried to do the last
number of years is a disgrace to the legal system
and a front to the New York State taxpayers
and a violation of the solemn rights and
protections afforded by the United States
Constitution. She developed. I once asked,
If you're innocent, why are you
taking the Fifth Amendment? I was
asking that question. Now I know the answer to
that question. When your family, your company,
and all the people in your orbit have become the
targets of an unfounded, politically motivated
witch hunt, supported by lawyers, prosecutors,
and even the fake news media, you really have
no choice. We cannot permit a renegade and out of
control prosecutor to use this investigation as a
means of advancing her political career. New York
deserves better in this country. Deserves better.
This is a vindictive and self-serving fishing
expedition, the likes of which this country
has perhaps never seen before. If
there was any question in my mind
the raid on my home two days ago,
Mar a Lago, Palm Beach, Florida,
by the FBI just two days prior to this deposition.
Think of it wiped out any of that uncertainty. I
have absolutely no choice because the current
administration and many prosecutors in this
country have lost all moral and ethical
bounds of decency. Anyone in my position
not taking the Fifth Amendment would be a fool,
an absolute fool. One statement or answer that is
ever so slightly off, just ever so
slightly by accident and by mistake,
such as it was a sunny and beautiful day
when actually it was slightly overcast,
would be met by law enforcement at a level seldom
seen in this country because I've experienced it.
The United States Constitution exists for
this very purpose, and I will utilize it to
the fullest extent and defend myself against
this malicious attack by this administration,
this attorney general's office, and all other
attacks on my family, my business and our country.
Accordingly, under the advice of my counsel and
for all of the above reasons, I respectfully
decline to answer the questions under the rights
and privileges afforded to every citizen under
the United States Constitution. This will be my
answer to any further questions. So, Mr. Trump, I
take it you are not going to answer any questions.
Speaker 1: About your preparation today with your
counsel. Is that correct?
Speaker 5:
When should I say this or should I respond to
that? Read that for all of the reasons provided
in my answer, which is incorporated herein. In
its entirety. I declined to answer the question.
Okay. Mr. Trump, the focus of our investigation.
Speaker 1: And what we are
primarily going to cover.
Speaker 5: Today involves the presentation
of your statements of financial condition between
2011 and the present. I take it you are generally
familiar with those statements.
Speaker 1: Is that correct?
Speaker 5: For all the reasons provided in my
answer, which is incorporated herein. In its
entirety. I declined to answer the question. Okay.
Speaker 1: One. How mopey. What a sad sack. Donald
Trump is their ex president of the United
States of America. Remember when he stood on
the balcony and gasping for breath, desperate to
look like a strong man? What happened to that guy
is so sad. You're asking me questions. I
plead the Fifth. There's several things
there that I want to talk about, though, that the
Constitution exists for this exact reason that if
I say it's sunny outside when it was actually
cloudy. Law enforcement's going to show up the
likes of which we've never seen. It's to call
it hyperbole isn't doing justice to hyperbole.
That now I know, he says, I was just asking
that question. Why would someone take the
Fifth Amendment when they weren't guilty if they
were not guilty? Now, I know the answer to that
question. He wasn't asking a rhetorical question.
He was making a statement. It was declaratory. Oh,
if you do this, it's like the mob. Only
guilty people take the fifth, he said.
And then I want to remind you and the audience,
dear listener, dear viewer, that taking the Fifth
Amendment, it is a right under the Constitution
of the United States against being forced to self
incriminate. It's not I don't want to testify.
Therefore, I'm going to take the Fifth Amendment.
It's not I'm tired today. Therefore, I'm pleading
the Fifth Amendment. That's not what it exists
for. It exists. If you committed a crime, you
cannot be compelled to testify against yourself.
So by him taking the fifth 400 times in this case,
it means he believes, reasonably believes he could
self incriminate by answering the questions. Very
telling. Very telling. I know a lot of people out
there. This is never going to go anywhere.
This is never going to be any consequence. I
am not so quick on that answer. I think that
there's a very good chance that he is going
to face consequences, maybe not as quickly as
we would like, but I believe it could happen.
I'd love to have you connect with me again.
I am dallimore on on the social media's,
and I'm right here on YouTube. Jesse Dallimore.